so what's going on in Florida then we
have DeSantis just kind of announced can
you help him at all like what's the deal
he sounds unbelievably corny he is and
everybody
say it this is the guy like he has all
the right ideas and this and then you
hear him talk and you just imagine like
him pushing his bifocals up his nose
every single sentence is that your guy
sure yeah so so let me explain it from a
different perspective
it's not but I'm telling you right now
yeah trust me if you go watch my Clips
there their Camp can't stand what I say
how the hell do you announce presidency
third week of May and you'll launch your
book February 28th and you promoted
based on going on two different
interviews they do 10 minutes 15 minutes
whatever how many interviews did it you
don't go on Megan Kelly you don't go on
different podcasts or sell the book you
don't go anywhere everybody forgot about
your book oh I just wrote the book you
didn't just write the book you wrote the
book because that's how you run for
office you write a book you make your
launch on Elon Musk and yesterday on the
launch he would have said if you want to
know what I stand for read my book one
read my book two go to this website and
yesterday would have been the number one
book on Amazon
few hundred thousand people would have
bought the book then the next
promotional layer comes in then he would
have sold a few million copies now we're
sitting there saying well I like the way
he explained this with his upbringing I
like so complete screw up on the
marketing side I have I don't understand
what they did there we were with them a
couple weeks ago at the Governor's
Mansion for six hours they invited a
small group of 10 or 15 people to sit
there and watch them on what's going on
just to see how he handled himself and
and I'm kind of watching the whole thing
these are all guys that are dissented
great guys you know some of these names
that are in there uh I'm in Florida
because of him when we were in Texas and
we're thinking about where to build a
media company it was going back to
Newport Beach it was coming down here to
Greenwich
it was going to Tennessee it was Tampa
Fort Lauderdale or staying in Dallas
DeSantis is the reason why we are in
Fort Lauderdale because if Texas which
we love in California which we love many
parts of if those two guys maybe it's
Florida okay so you know the the the and
by the way the floor is waiting for you
as well to make your move down there
here you know so it's gonna take a
minute
[Laughter]
you know but but the point is Florida to
me uh uh with what he's done great now
here's a question watch this question I
ask you guys how you answer this okay
who's here I love you
here
watch this when I answered this mop the
floor with all these guys dude it sucks
it sucks you have to be born in America
to be president because you would mop
the yeah with these guys
like Impractical Jokers put an earpiece
in them or something I just don't know
if the Santa says the Charisma and I
want to get back to it but like there's
just something so funny about you going
up against these guys I wonder if we
discussed this on your pod if you do
military service
maybe you get to run for president
if you want to die for the country
yeah
I want to be Chinese
than you you didn't serve well see
called after 9 11 and knew nothing
[Music]
but you've chosen that I am pure-blooded
American not as much as him technically
more why because I'm born here
[Laughter]
so so maybe we have you run man we we
all campaign
I want you to be president but I want
you to I want you to mop the floor with
these guys I think it'd be really funny
you you know it would be a lot of fun do
they do they melt when you're around
them or do they have some ego
it's not even why would you have an
ankle I can't compete why why would you
even be worried about that I'm not
competition so you can't even think like
automatic bro I didn't even think about
that like uh we were talking about this
the other day on the podcast like how
the how the Kardashians are brilliant at
like utilizing other famous people to
make them look more famous so Kendall
Jenner is courtside at the Lakers game
and she's dating Bad Bunny who's the
biggest star on the planet that's one
picture that kind of stuff how is how is
Bad Bunny this and she's you know he's
like this and she's not even looking at
him right and is this this genius
branding right to make her look like the
most desired thing on the planet when
you have the guy who is really the most
desired person on the planet like
begging for attention right and I wonder
if like
uh yeah I just I
the Kardashian brand can overpower
anybody that can't overpower Bad Bunny
you don't have the Hispanic audience the
way Bad Bunny does Bad Bunny is God to
the Hispanic Community you can't
overpower bad money bad money have you
had bad money here yet or no no I'd love
to see bad money with you guys whatever
you're watching this Bad Bunny you got
to be right here with these guys the
word and want to see this you heard it
uh oh I guess what I was trying to say
is they're not worried about you
competing about the other politics they
don't have to worry when they're
interacting with you whereas every other
person these politicians are interfacing
with publicly they have to make sure
that they're winning that Arrangement
winning that conversation because it
will be used against them I mean his
influence is huge so they have to worry
about that of course of course but the
way that their interfacing is different
like for example let's say Trump and
DeSantis are shaking hands and I know
all the cameras are there right DeSantis
can't be this little beta and like kind
of curling up against him DeSantis can
kiss your ass like he would a donor like
who would anybody else with influence
because he doesn't have to worry about
that kind of position yeah
ah potential competition let's just run
from Florida Governor dude just be
Florida governor no that's my question
if you can't be president what would you
be politically listen
no I have no desire to be a governor of
a state if you're a governor of Florida
I guarantee you can be president no no
listen that that part you're not
president in America but we'll find a
place
great that would be funny no I have no
desire for me here's the part though so
so the great thing is like when you know
you can't compete for this one thing
okay you know legally you can't laws
doesn't matter how much you can't say
you can't what if no there's you listen
you can't like when you know your
vertical you know you can only jump 20
inches I'm gonna go be a dunk contest
Champion like Spud Webb and I'm 5'7 bro
you're not going to pull it off you're
you've got a 20 inch vertical leap you
have nearly 50 inches right so in this
part I know it's not going to happen
what's the other part it could happen
what we will do is we will compete in a
media space and and we will compete in a
in a in a very big way right now man you
know what I'm doing right now I have
only one plan right now trying to put a
super team together brother that's the
only thing I'm thinking about that's all
I'm doing yeah all I'm doing right now
is putting a super team together of
people who love America who are remember
the whole name valuetainment is what you
have to bring value but you have to be
entertaining yeah if you're not
entertaining our brand doesn't fit you
your person you have to be able to
entertain because it's just as important
as bringing value but if you can do both
you're a validator even better one
question about the DeSantis quote
unquote flop when he made the
announcement yeah
now if I'm the pr guy
I say make it fail
on purpose I say Elon do me a favor have
the tech up make it look like you
know I'm getting caught off in a few
seconds make it look like we have to
reboot it because you own the news cycle
afterwards HBO the final episode of this
show that was a fantastic show but not a
lot of people are watching called mayor
of East Town in the final episode of
Mayor of East Town this is during the
pandemic
halfway through the episode The Stream
fails
Twitter is on fire you can't go on
Twitter without people talking about it
non-stop oh my God oh my God oh my God
brilliant listen he got Trump to make
fun of him about his address
so it's like you're almost playing the
Trump game so if I'm the marketing
people behind DeSantis yeah I win the
news cycle because everybody's talking
about me good bad doesn't matter and two
now I actually want to see what he was
saying so now you get the message across
do you think that that was planned
do you think they have somebody with
some balls on the campaign I think it's
less than one percent that was planned
because uh musk and sacks uh if you
listen to the entire recording musk and
sacks were also putting plugs into
Twitter in the future it was just as
much about Twitter's future and
mainstream media's future as it was
about the same so it can't fail Twitter
as well yeah I I think I think the brand
actually was elevated I would say 60
percentage but I thought it was 40
yesterday about Twitter spaces
mainstream media musk sacks what they're
doing uh yeah those guys those guys are
going to be players obviously this musk
is number one but in the media space
the game changed yesterday seven hundred
thousand people are watching this thing
and it crashes are you kid 700 000
people live in a room are waiting for
this and they have to go on Sax's
account because musk's 130 million
messed up the algorithm so they went on
sax got 650 and it was fine everybody
could listen to everything that was
being said and this the sentence made
this announcement yeah I think I think
uh Twitter is going to be I've said this
the day uh musk spot Twitter I did a
video and I said Twitter's going to be a
trillion Auto Company okay what they're
about to do with Twitter it's scary what
are they about yeah oh my gosh what a
great setup this is why you need to be
president
what we're about to do to China we'll be
back after the break
foreign